hello and welcome to continuous
integration tutorial using Jenkins
my name is Chad Annan and I am with the
simply loom team today let's get started
with Jenkins Jenkins in my opinion is
one of the most popular continuous
intelligence service of recent times
what began as a hobby project by a
developer working for Sun Microsystems
way back in early or mid 2000s has
gradually and eventually evolved into a
very very powerful and robust automation
service it has a wide adoption since it
is released under MIT license and is
almost free to use Jenkins has a vast
developer community that supports it by
writing all kinds of plugins plugins is
the heart and soul of Jenkins because
using plugins one can connect Jenkins to
anything and everything under the Sun
with that introduction let's get into
what all will be covered as a part of
this tutorial I will get into some of
the prerequisites required for
installing Jenkins post which I will go
ahead and install Jenkins on a Windows
box there are a few first M
configuration that needs to be done and
I will be covering those as well
so once I have Jenkins installed and
configured properly I will get into the
user administrative part create free
users and I will use some plugins for
setting up various kinds of access
permissions for this users I will also
put in some freestyle jobs
freestyle job is nothing but a very very
simple job and I will also show you the
powerfulness of Jenkins by scheduling
this particular job to run based upon
time schedule I will also connect
Jenkins with github github is our source
code where source code repository where
I've got some repositories put up there
so using Jenkins I will connect to
github pull up a repository that is
existing on github onto the Jenkins box
and run few commands to build this
particular repository that is pulled
from github sending out emails is a very
very important configurations of Jenkins
or any other continuous integration
server for that matter whenever there is
any notifications that has to be sent
out as a part of either build going bad
or by being good or will being
propagated to some environment and all
these scenarios you would need the
content integration servers to be
sending our notifications so I will get
into a little bit
details of how to configure Jenkins for
sending out emails I will also get into
a scenario where I will have a web
application a maven based Java web
application which will be pulled from a
github repository and I will deploy it
onto a tomcat server the Tomcat server
will be locally running on my system
eventually I will get into one other
very very important topic which is the
master slave configuration it's a very
very important and pretty interesting
topic where distributed builds is
achieved using a master slave
configuration so I will bring up a slave
I will connect the slave with the master
and I will also put in a job and kind of
delegate that particular job to the
slave configuration finally I will let
you know how to use some plugins to
backup your Jenkins
so Jenkins has got lot of useful
information set up on it in terms of the
build environments in terms of workspace
all this can be very very easily backed
up using a plugin so this is what I'm
going to be covering as a part of this
tutorial
Jenkins is a web application that is
written in Java and there are various
ways in which you can use and install
Jenkins I have listed popular three
mechanisms in which Dinkins is usually
installed on in any system the topmost
one is as a Windows or a Linux based
services so if at all you have Windows
like the way I have and I'm going to use
this mechanism for this demo so I would
download a MSI installer that is
specific to Jenkins and install this
service so whenever installed as a
service it goes out and nicely installs
all that is required for my Jenkins and
I have a service that can be started or
stopped based upon my need any flavor of
Linux as well one other way of running
Jenkins is downloading this generic war
file and as long as you have JDK
installed you can launch this war file
by the command opening up a command
prompt or shell prompt different earlier
on linux box specifying java
- jar and the name of this war file
typically brings up your web application
and you know you can continue with your
installation the only thing being if at
all you want to stop using Jenkins you
just go ahead and close this prompt you
either do a ctrl C and then bring down
this prompt and it's in conserve what
would be down other older versions of
Jenkins were run popularly using this
way in which you already have a Java
based web server running up and running
so you kind of drop in this war file
into the root folder or the HTTP root
folder of your
flip server so Jenkins would explode and
kind of bring up your application all
user credentials or user administration
is all taken care of by the Apache or
the Tomcat server or the web server on
which Jenkins is running this was a very
older way of running but still some
people use it because if they don't want
to maintain two servers if they already
have a Java web server which it's being
nicely maintained and backed up Jenkins
can't run attach to it
all right so either ways it doesn't
matter however you gonna bring up your
Jenkins instance the way we're gonna
operate Jenkins is all going to be very
very same or similar on but the subtle
changes in terms of user administration
if at all you're launching it through
any other web server which we take care
of the user administration otherwise all
the commands or all the configuration or
the way in which I'm going to run this
demo it is going to be same across any
of these installations all right so the
prerequisites for running Jenkins as I
mentioned earlier Jenkins is nothing but
a simple web application there is run in
Java so all that it needs is Java
preferably jdk 1.7 or 1.8 2gb ram is the
recommended ram for running jenkins and
also like any other open-source tool
sets when you install jdk ensure that
you set in the environment variable Java
home to point to the right directory
this is something very specific to JDK
but for any other open source tools that
you've installed there is always a
preferred environment variable that you
got to sit in which is specific to that
particular tool that you're gonna use
this is a generic thing that is there
for you know for any other open source
projects because the Wade open source
projects discover themselves he's using
this environment variables so as a
general practice or a good practice
always set these environment variables
accordingly so I already have jdk 1.8
installed on my system but in case you
do not what I would recommend is just
navigate on your browser to the Oracle
home page and just type in our search
for install jdk 1.8
[Music]
License Agreement and there are a bunch
of installers that is okay that he can
pick up based upon the operating system
one which you're running so I have this
Windows 64 installer that is already
installed and running on my system so I
will not get into the details of
downloading this or installing it let me
show you once I install this what I've
done with regard to my path so if you
get into this environment variables
alright so I have just sit in a Java
home variable if you see this C colon
program files Java JDK 1.8 this is where
my my Java is located see Program Files
see Program Files Java okay so this is
the home directory of my jdk so that is
what I've been I've set it up here in my
environment variable so if you see here
this is my Java home all right one
the thing to do is ensure that in case
you want to run Java or Java Sea from a
command from and show that you also add
that path into this path variable so if
you see this somewhere I will see yes
there you go
sequel in Program Files Java JDK 1.8 pin
so with these two I will ensure that my
Java installation is nice and you know
good enough so to check that to
double-check that or to verify that let
me just open up a simple command prompt
type in Java - version alright and Java
C - version so the compiler is on the
path Java is on the path and if at all I
do this
even the environment variable specific
to my Java is installed correctly so I
am good to go ahead with my Jenkins
installation now that I have my
prerequisites all set for installing
Jenkins let me just go ahead and
download Jenkins so let me open up a
browser and say download Jenkins alright
LTS is nothing but the long-term support
these are all stable versions weeklies I
would not recommend that you try these
unless until you have a real need for
that long-term support is good enough
and as I mentioned there are so many
flavors of Jenkins there is available
for download you also have a docker
container wherein you know you can
launch in Kinser containers but I won't
get into details of that in this
tutorial alright so what I want is yes
this is the war file with a generic war
file that I was talking to you earlier
and this is the Windows MSI installer so
go ahead and in download this MSI
installer I already have that downloaded
so let me just open that up alright so
this is my downloaded Jenkins instance a
rather installer this is a pretty maybe
a few months old but this is good enough
for me before you start jenkins
installation just be aware of one fact
that there is a variable called Jenkins
home this is where jenkins put store all
this configuration data our jobs for
that work space and all that specific to
Jenkins so by default if at all you
don't set this to any particular
directory if at all you install an MSI
installer all your installation gets
into C colon program files 86 and
Jenkins folder if at all you run a war
file depending upon the user ID with
which you're running your war file the
Jenkins folder there's a dot Jenkins
folder that gets created inside the user
home directory so in case you have any
need wherein you want to backup your
Jenkins already one Jenkins
installations to get into some specific
directories go ahead and set this
Jenkins home variable accordingly before
you even begin your installation for now
I don't need to do any of this thing so
I've already downloaded the Installer
let me just go ahead with the default
installation alright so this is my
Jenkins MSI installer I would just I
want to make any changes into the
Jenkins configuration C colon program
files is good for me yeah this is where
all my destination folder and all the
configuration specific to it goes I'm
happy with us I don't wanna change this
I would just say go ahead and click
installation okay so what typically
happens once the Jenkins installation
gets through is it'll start installing
itself and there is some small checks
that needs to be done so and by default
Jenkins launches on the port 8080 so let
me just open up localhost 8080 there's a
small checking that will be done as a
part of the installation process wherein
I need to type in the hash key alright
so there's a very very simple hash key
that gets stole out here so I'll have to
just copy this path
if at all you're running as a war file
you would see that in your logs alright
so this is a simple hash key that gets
created every time when you do a
Jenkinson station so as a part of the
installation it just asks you to do this
so if that is not correct
it will crib about it but this looks
good so it's going ahead
all right one important part during the
installation so you would need to
install some recommended plugins what
happens is the plugins are all related
to each other so it's like the typical
rpm kind of a problem where you try to
install some plug-in and it's got a
dependency which is not installed and
you get into all those issues in order
to get rid of that what jenkins
recommends there's a bunch of plugins
that is already recommended so just go
ahead and blindly click that install
recommended plugin so if you see there
is a whole lot of plugins which are bare
essential plugins that is required for
Jenkins in order to run properly so
Jenkins as a part of the installation
would get all these plugins and then
install it for you this is a good
combination to kind of begin with and
mind you at this moment Jenkins needs
lots of bandwidth in in terms of network
so in case your you know your network is
not so good few of these plugins would
kind of fail and these plugins are all
you know unavailable on openly or or
mirrored sites and sometimes some of
them may be down so do not worry in case
some of these plugins kind of fail to
install you get an option to kind of
retry installing them but just ensure
that you know at least most or 90 95
percent of all these plugins are
installed without any problems let me
pause the video here for a minute and
then get back once all these plugins are
installed my plug-in the installation is
all good there was no failures in any of
my plugins so after that I get to create
his first admin user again this is one
important point that you got to remember
Kien given any username and password but
ensure that you kind of remember that
because it's very hard to get back your
username and password in case you forget
it
all right so I'm gonna create a very
very simple username and password
something that I can remember I will
that's my name and an email ID is kind
of optional but it doesn't allow me to
go ahead in case I don't so I just given
an admin and I got a password I've got I
remember my password this is my full
name all right has his seven finish
all right that kind of completed my
Jenkins installation does not that tough
was it now that I have my Jenkins
installed correctly
let me quickly walk you through some
very minimal configurations that is
required these are kind of a first-time
configuration that is required so and
also let me warn you the UI is little
hard for many people to wrap their head
around it pacifically the windows guys
but if at all your of java guy you know
how painful it is to write UI in java
you kind of appreciate you know all the
effort that has gone into the UI bottom
line he was little hard to you know wrap
your head around it but once you start
using it presumably you start liking it
alright so let me get into something
called as managing kins this can be
viewed like a main menu for all Jenkins
configuration so I will get into some of
those important ones something called as
configure a system configuration this is
where you kind of put in the
configuration for your complete Jenkins
instance few things to kind of look out
for this is a home directory this is a
Java home where all the configurations
all the workspace anything and
everything regarding Jenkins is store
out here system message you want to put
in some message on the system he just
type in whatever you want and he's
probably show up somewhere up here on
the menu number of executors very very
important configuration this just lets
junk in know at any point in time how
many jobs or how many threads can be run
you can you can kind of visualize it
like a thread that can be run on this
particular instance as a thumb rule if
at all you are on a single core system
number of executors to should be good
enough in case at any point in time if
there are multiple jobs that kind of get
trigger at the same time in case the
number of executors are less compared to
the number of jobs that are there to
open up no need to panic because they
will all get chewed up and eventually
Jenkins will get to running those jobs
just bear in mind that whenever a new
job kind of FINA gets triggered the CPU
usage and the memory usage in terms of
the disk write is very high on Stinky's
instance so that's something that you
gotta kind of keep in mind alright but
number of executors too for my system is
kind of good
for my Jenkins I don't want any of these
things usage how do you want to use your
Jenkins this is good for him because I
only have a primary server that is
running so I want to use this lor as
much as possible
quite prayer each of these options have
got some bare minimal help kind of a
thing that is there is out chair by
clicking on these question marks you
will get to know as to what are these
particular configurations all right so
this all look good what I want to show
you here is there's something regarding
the docker timestamp skit plug-in
Isthmian email notifications I don't
want that what I want the yeast
I want this SMTP server configuration
remember I mentioned earlier that I
would want Jenkins to be sending out
some emails and what I've done here is
I've just configured the SMTP details of
my personal email ID in case you are in
know in organization you would have some
sort of an email ids that is set up for
a Jenkins server so you can specify the
SMTP server details of your company so
that you know you can authorize Jenkins
to kind of send out emails but in case
you wanna try it out like we I have
configured my personal email ID which is
on my Gmail for sending out
notifications so this MTP server would
be smtp.gmail.com using the SMTP
authentication
I have provided my email ID and my
password I am using SMTP port which is
465 and I'm you know reply to address is
the same as mine I can just send out an
email and see if at all this
configuration works again Gmail would
not allow you to allow anybody to send
out notifications on your behalf so
you'll have to lower the security level
of your gmail ID so that you can allow
programmatically somebody to send out
email notifications on your behalf so
I've done already that I'm just trying
to see if I can send a test email with
the configurations that I've set in
yes all right so the email configuration
looks good so this is how you configure
your you know your Gmail account in case
you want to do that if not put in your
organization SMTP server details which
are for the valid username and password
and should all be set all right so no
other configuration that I want to
change here all of these look good
all right so I come back to managing
Ken's okay one other thing that I want
to kind of goal is the global tone
configuration imagine this scenario look
at it this way Jenkins is a is a
continuous integration server it doesn't
know what kind of a codebase it's gonna
pull in what kind of a tool says that is
required or what is the code that is
gonna pull in and how is it gonna build
so you would have to put in all the
tools that is required for building the
appropriate kind of code that you're
gonna pull in from you know your source
code repositories so this to you an
example in case your source code is a
Java source code and assuming that you
know because in this demo this is my
laptop and I've put in all the
configurations GDK everything on my
laptop because I am a developer I am
working on the laptop but my country's
innovation server would be you know a
separate server without anything being
installed on it so in case I want
Jenkins to you know run a Java core I
would need to install JDK on it I need
to specify the JDK location of this out
here this way
okay since I already have the JDK
installed and I've already put in the
Java whom directly or rather and the
environment variable correctly I don't
need to do it get if at all I want the
Jenkins server to use git git is a you
know command bash or the command prompt
for for running git and connecting to
any other git server so you would need
get to be you know install on that
particular system and set the path
accordingly Gradle and mavin if at all
you have some Mavin's as well you want
to do this any other tool that you're
gonna install on your system which is
your continuous integration server you
will have to come in here and configure
something in case you don't configure it
when shinkansen runs it will not be able
to find these tools for building your
tasks and it'll crib about it
that's good I don't want to save
anything managing canes let me see what
else is required yes configure global
security
enabled and if you see by default it's
the security access control is set to
Jenkins own user database so what does
this mean
you know Jenkins by default it uses file
system where it stores all the user
names which hashes up these user names
and kind of stores them so as of now it
Jenkins is configured to use its own
database assuming that you are running
in an organization you would probably
want to have a you know some sort of an
ad or an LDAP server using which you
would want to control access to your
Jenkins repository rather Jenkins tune
so you would specify your LDAP server
details the root DN password or the
manager DN and the manager password and
all these details in case you want to
connect your Jenkins instance with your
LDAP or ad or any of the authentication
servers that you have in your
organization but for now since I don't
have any of these things I'm going to
use this own database that's good enough
all right so I will set up some
authorization methods and stuff like
that once I put in few jobs so for now
let me not get into any of these details
of this just be aware that Jenkins can
be connected for authorization to an
LDAP server or you can have Jenkins
managing its own service which is
happening as of now so I'm going to save
all this stuff that's good for me so
enough of all these configurations let
me put in a very very simple job all
right
so job new item you know little
difficult to kind of figure out but then
that's the new item so I will just say
you know first job this was good for me
I just give a name for my job I would
say it's a freestyle project that's good
enough for me I don't want to choose any
of that so unless until you choose any
of this this particular button would not
become active so choose the freestyle
project and say okay
at a very high level you would see
general source code management bill
triggers beta environment build and post
build in case you install more and more
plugins you will see lot more options
but for now this is what you would see
so what am i doing at the moment I'm
just putting up a very very simple job
and the job could be anything and
everything so I don't want to put in a
very complicated job for now for the
demo what was never just put in a very
very simple job I'll give a description
this is an optional thing this is my
first Jenkins job alright I don't want
to choose any of these again there are
some helps available here
I don't want to choose any of this I
don't want to connect it to do any
source code for now I don't want any
triggers for now I'll come back to this
in in a while
build environment I don't want any build
environment as a part of this build step
you know I just want to you know run few
things so that I kind of complete this
particular job
so since I'm one of Windows books I
would say execute windows batch command
all right so what do you want to do I
would let me just echo something echo
hello this is my first Jenkins job and
possibly I would want the date and the
time stamp
pertaining to the job I mean the date
and time in which this job was run all
right
very very simple command that says you
know this is my first job it just puts
out something along with the date and
the time all right I don't want to do
anything else
I want to keep this job as simple as
this so let me save this job all right
so once you save this job you know the
job names comes up here and then I need
to build this job and he would see some
Billy stay out here nothing is there as
of now because I've just put in a job I
have not run it yet all right so let me
try to build it now
you see a big number you will see a date
and a timestamp so if I click on this
you will see a console output if I go
here
okay as simple as that and where is all
the job details that is getting into if
you see this
to this particular directory all right
so this is the directory what I was
mentioning earlier regarding Jenkins
home so all the job related stuff that
is specific to this particular Jenkins
installation is all here
all the plugins that is installed the
details of each of those plugins can be
found here all right
so the workspace is where all the jobs
that I've created which ever I'm running
we're on there will be individual
folders specific to the jobs that has
been put up here all right so one job
one quick run that's what it looks like
pretty simple okay let me do one thing
let me put up a second job
can job
it's a freestyle project
second job
I just want to demonstrate the
powerfulness of the automation server
and how simple it is to automate a job
that is put up on Jenkins
which will be triggered automatically
remember what I said earlier about
Jenkins because at the core of Jenkins
is a very very powerful automation
server alright so what I'm gonna do I
will just keep everything else the same
I'm gonna put in a build script prima
similar to second job that gets
triggered automatically every minute all
right let me do that
percentage date and now put in the time
alright so I just put it on the job
called second job and it pretty much
does the same thing as what I was doing
earlier in terms of printing the date
and the time but this time I'm just
going to demonstrate the powerfulness of
the automation server that is there if
you see here there's a bill trigger so a
build can be triggered using various
triggers that is there so we'll get into
this github triggering or hook or a web
hook kind of a triggering later on but
for now what I want to do I want to
ensure that this job that I'm gonna put
in would be automatically triggered on
its own let's say every minute I want
this job to be run on its own so build
periodically is my setting if you see
here as a bunch of help that is
available for me so for those of you you
have written cron jobs on Linux boxes
you'll find it very very simple but for
others don't panic then we just put up a
very very simple regular expression for
scheduling this job every minute all
right so that's one two three four five
all right come up
so five stars is all that I'm gonna put
in and Jenkins got a little worried and
she's asking me do you really mean every
minute oh yeah I wanna do this every
minute let me save this and how do I
check whether it gets triggered every
minute or not I just don't do anything I
just wait for a minute and if at all
everything goes well Jenkins would
automatically trigger my second job in a
minutes time from now
this time around I'm not going to
trigger anything look they see it's
automatically got trigger
if I go in here yep second row of the
triggered automatically you know it was
242 1642 which is 442 my time that looks
good
and if everything goes well every one
minute onwards this job would be
automatically triggered now that I have
my Jenkins up and running a few jobs
that has been put up here on my Jenkins
instance I would need a way of
controlling access to my Jenkins server
this is wherein I would use a plug-in
called role-based access plug-in and
create few rules the rules are something
like a global rule and a project rule
for a specific road I can have different
rules and I can have users who have
signed up or the users whom I create
kind of assigned to these rules so that
each of these users fall into some
category this is my way of kind of
controlling access to my Jenkins
instance and ensuring that people don't
do something unwarranted all right so
first things first let me go ahead and
install a plugin for doing that so I get
into manage Jenkins and manage plug-in a
little bit of a confusing screen in my
opinion there is updates available
installed in advance as of now we don't
have the role-based plug-in so let me go
to available it'll take some time for it
to get refreshed
alright now these are the available
plugins these are the installed plugins
alright so let me come back to available
and I will want to search for my role
based access plugin so I would say
search for role and hit enter
okay role-based authorization strategy
enables user authorization using a role
based strategy roles can be defined
globally or for particular jobs or nodes
and stuff like that so exactly this is
the plugin that I want I would want to
install it without a restart
right looks good so far yes go back to
the top of the page yes I remember
Jenkins is running on a Java using a
Java instance so typically many things
would work the same way and essentially
you want to restart Jenkins once in a
while but as a good practice whenever
you do some sort of big installations or
big patches on your Jenkins instance
just ensure that you can have restart it
otherwise there would be a difference in
terms of what is installed on the system
and what is there on the file system you
will need to flush out few of those
settings later on but for now these are
all very small plugins so these would
run without any problems but otherwise
if at all there are some plugins which
they would need a restart you kindly go
in and restart your Jenkins instance but
for now I don't need that it looks good
I have installed the plug-in so where do
I see my plugin i install the plugin
that is specific to the user control or
the access control so let me go into yes
global security and I would see this
role based energy showing up now all
right so this comes in because of my
installation of my role-based plugin so
this is what I would want to enable
because I already have my own database
set up and for the authorization part in
the sense that who can do what I am
going to install I mean I have already
installed a role based strategy plug-in
and I'm going to enable that strategy
all right I would say save ok now I've
installed the role based access plug-in
I would need to just set it up and check
that you know I would go ahead and
create some roles and ensure that I
assign users as per these roles all
right so let me go to manage and Cane's
configure all right let me see where is
this configure configure global security
is that where I create my roles
nope not here
yes managing assigned roles
okay again you would see these options
only after you install these plugins so
for now I've just enabled the plug-in I
have enabled role-based access control
and I would go ahead and create some
rules for this particular Jenkins
instance so I would say first manage
rules
so I would need to create some roles
here and the roles are at a very high
level these are global rules and there
are some project roles and there are
some slave roles I'll not get into
details of all of these at a very very
high level which is a global role let me
just create a role a role can be kind of
visualize like a group so I would create
our own called developer typically the
Jenkins instance or the CIA instance are
kind of old up or controlled by QA guys
so QA guys would need to provide some
sort of you know limited access to
developers so that's why I am creating a
rule called developer and I'm adding
this role at a global role level so I
would say and this here and you would
see this developer rule that is there
and each of these options you fake
horror over it you would see some sort
of a help on what what are these you
know permissions specific to so what I
want is like you know it sounds a little
you know different but I would want to
give very very little permissions for
the developer so from an administration
perspective I would just want him to
have a read kind of a rule credentials
again I would just want a view kind of a
rule I don't want him to create any
agents and all that stuff that's good
for me for a job I would want him to
just possibly read I don't want him to
build I don't want him to cancel any
jobs I don't want him to configure any
job I don't even want him to create any
job I would just want him to read
through things I would not give him
possibly a role to the workspace as well
I mean I don't want him to have access
to the workspace I would just want him
to read a job Oh check you know have
read-only access to the job run um no I
don't want him to give him any any
particular access which will allow him
to run any jobs view configure yeah
possibly create yeah delete I don't want
to read yes definitely and this is the
specific role so what I'm doing I am
just creating a global role called
developer and I'm giving him very very
limited roles in the sense that I don't
want this developer to be able to run
any agents nor create jobs or build jobs
or cancel jobs or configure jobs at the
max I would just want him to read a job
there is already put up there okay so I
would save now I created a rule I still
don't have any users that is there on
the system so let me go ahead and create
some user on the system that's not here
how to configure manage and Kanes manage
users okay let me create a new user I
would call this user as a developer one
sounds good
some password some password that I can
remember okay
his name is developer 1d8 t.com or
something like that
okay so this is the admin with with
which I kind of configure our part of
the system and developer one is a user
that I have configured so still have not
set any rules for this particular user
yet so I would go to manage and gains I
would say manage and assign roles I
would say assign roles
okay so if you see what I'm going to do
now is assign a role that is specific to
that particular girl I will find the
particular user and assign him the
developer role that I have already
configured the rule shows up here I
would need to find my user whoever
created and then assign him to that
particular rule so if you remember the
user that I created was a developer one
I would add this particular user and now
this particular user what kind of a role
I want him to have because this is the
global rule that had created so
developer I would assign this developer
one to this particular global rule and I
would go ahead and save my changes now
let me check the permissions of this
particular user by logging out of my
admin account and logging back as
developer one if you remember this role
was created with very less privileges so
there you go
I have Jenkins but I don't see a new
item I can't trigger a new job I can't
do anything I see these jobs however I
don't think so I'll be able to start
this job I don't have the permission set
for that the maximum I can do is look at
the job see what was there as a part of
the console output and stuff like that
so this is a limited role that was
created and I added this developer to
that particular role which was a
developer role so that the developers
don't get to configure any of the jobs
because the Jenkins instance is owned by
a QA person he doesn't want to give
developer any administrative rights so
the rights that he set out by creating a
developer role and anybody who is tagged
any user who's tagged as a part of this
developer role would get the same kind
of permissions and these permissions can
be you know fine grain it can be a
project specific permissions as well but
for now I just demonstrated the high
level permission that I had set in let
me quickly log out of this user and get
back as the admin user because I need to
continue with my demo with the developer
role that was created I have very very
less privileges one of the reasons for
Jenkins being so popular as I mentioned
earlier is the bunch of plugins that is
provided by users or community users who
don't charge any money for these plugins
but it's got plugins for
or connecting anything and everything so
if you can navigate to or if you can
find Jenkins plugins
you would see index of over so many
plugins that is there all of these are
wonderful plugins whatever connectors
that you would need if you want to
connect Jenkins to an AWS instance or
you wanna connect shangkun's to a darker
instance or any of those containers you
would have a plug-in you can go and
search up if I want to connect Jenkins
to big bucket it pocket is one of the
good servers so many plugins that is
available okay so bottom line Jenkins
without plugins is nothing so plugins is
the heart of Jenkins for you to connect
or for in order to connect Jenkins with
any of the containers or any of the
other tool sets you would need the
plugins if you want to connect or you
want to build a repository which has got
Java and mavin you would need to install
mavin and JDK on its Incans instance if
at all you're looking for a dotnet build
or a Microsoft build you would need to
have MS build installed on you on your
Jenkins instance and the plugins that
will trigger msbuild if at all you want
to listen to some server-side web hooks
from github
you will need get up specific plugins if
you want to connect Jenkins to AWS you
need those plugins if you want to
connect to a docker instance that is
running anywhere in the world as long as
you have the URL which is publicly
reachable you just have a docker plug-in
that is installed on your Jenkins
instance sonar cube is one of the
popular static code analysis so you can
connect a Jenkins build you can build a
job on Jenkins and push it to sonarqube
and get sonar cube to run analysis on
that and get back the results in Jenkins
all of these works very well because of
the plugins now with that let me connect
our Jenkins instance to github I already
have very very simple Java repository up
on my github instance so let me connect
Jenkins to this particular github
instance and pull out a job that is put
up there alright so this is my very very
simple you know repository that is there
called hello Java and this is what is
there in the repository say hello hello
dot java application that is here or a
simple class file that is there it's got
just one line of system dot out so this
is already present on github.com at this
place and this would be the URL for this
repository
if I pick up the HTTP URL this is my
steepest URL so what I would do is I
would connect my Jenkins instance to go
to github provide my credentials and
pull out this repository which is on the
cloud hosted github.com and get it to my
Jenkins instance and then build this
particular Java file of keeping the
source code very very simple it's just a
Java file how do I build my Java file
how do I compile my Java file I just say
Java C and the name of my class file
which is hello Java and how do I run my
Java file I would say Java and hello
okay so remember I don't need to install
any plugins now because what it needs is
a get plug-in so if you remember when we
were doing the installation there was a
bunch of recommended plugins so gate is
already installed on my system so I
don't need to install it again
so let me put up a new job here he says
good job that'd be a freestyle project
that's good for me I would say okay
so the source code management remember
in the earlier examples we did not use
any source code because we were just
putting up some echo kind of jobs did
not need any integration with any of the
source code systems so now let me
connect this so I'm gonna put up a
source code and it would show up because
the plug-in is already there is Fein
perforce
any of those additional source code
management tools if at all you would
need just install those plugins and
Jenkins connects wonderfully well to all
this particular source control tools
okay so I would copy the HTTP URL from
here I would say this is the URL that
I'm supposed to go and grab my source
code from but alright that sounds good
but what is the username and password so
I'll have to specify a username
and password all right so I would say
the username this is my username and
this is my HTTP credential for my job
okay so this is my username and this is
my password
I just saved this I say add and then I
would say you know use these credentials
to go to github and then on my behalf
pull out a repository alright if at all
at this stage if there's any errors in
terms of not able to Jenkins not able to
find gate or the get dot exe or if my
credentials are wrong somewhere down
here you would see a red message saying
that you know something is not right can
just go ahead and kind of fix that for
now this looks good for me I'm gonna
grab this URL what am I gonna do the
step would pull the source code from the
github and then what would be there as a
part of my build step because this
repository just has a Java file correct
hello Java so in order to for me to
build this I would just say execute
windows batch command and I would say
Java C hello dot Java that is the way I
would build my java core and if I have
to run it I would just say Java hello
pretty simple two steps and this would
run after the repository contents are
fetched from github so Java C Java that
sounds good I would say save this and
let me try to run this okay if you see
there's a lot of you know it executed
skit on your behalf it goes out here it
provides my credentials and says you
know it pulls all my repository and by
default it will pull up the master
branch that is there on my posit or e
and it kind of builds this whole thing
Java C hello to Java and it runs this
project Java hello and there you see
this is the output that is there and if
at all you want to look at the contents
of the repository if you can go here
this is mine
workspace of my system hang on this is
not right okay good job if you see here
this is my hello no Java this is the
same program that was there on my github
repository
okay so this is a program that was there
on github repository alright so this was
the same program that was here and
Jenkins on our behalf went over all the
way to github pull this repository from
there and then you know he brought it
down to my local system on my Jenkins
instance it compiled it and it ran this
particular application okay now that
I've integrated Jenkins successfully
with get out for a simple the java
application let me build a little bit on
top of it what I will do is I have a
maven based web application that is up
there as a repository in my github so
this is the repository that I'm talking
about
it's called Amy and web app it's got
it's a mavin based repository as we
would know mavin is a very very simple
java based build tool that will allow
you to run various targets and it will
compile it will based upon the goals
that you specify it can compile it can
run some tests and it can you can build
a war file and even deploy it into some
other server for now what we gonna use
maven is just for building and creating
a package out of this particular web
application it contains a bunch of
things and what is important is just the
index dot JSP it just contains an HTML
file that is there as a part of this web
application so from a perspective of
requirements now since I'm gonna connect
Jenkins with this particular posit or II
get we already have that set we only
need two other things one is mavin
because Jenkins will use maven so in
order to use maven Jenkins would have to
have a Merrin installation that is there
on the Jenkins box and in this case the
think is box is this laptop
after I have a MAV uninstall I also need
a tomcat server tomcat is a very very
simple web server and then you can
freely download I'll let you know how to
quickly download and install the Tomcat
alright so download mavin first
at the various ways in which you can
kind of download this man there is zip
files binary zip files an archive file
so what I've done is I've just already
downloaded my own and if you see I won
zipped it here so this is the folder
with which I have unzipped my mavin so
as you know mavin again is is a one
open-source build tool so you'll have to
sit in a few configurations and set up
the path so MVN - - version if I specify
this after I set in my path
Mammon should work and if at all I echo
m2 home which is nothing but the
variable environment variable specific
to my OneNote it is already set here so
once you unzip mavin just set this m2
home variable to the directory video
unzipped your my one also just set the
path to this particular directory slash
bin because that is where your mavin
executables are all found all right so
that's with mavin and you know since
I've set the path and the environment
variable mavin is running perfectly fine
on my system I just verified it okay
next one is a tomcat server
download patch a tomcat server 8.5 is
what I have on my system so I'm just
going to show you where to download this
from
this way you don't know Tomcat server
and I already have the server downloaded
again this doesn't need any installation
I just unzip it here and it kind of has
a binden configuration I have made some
subtle changes in the configuration
first and foremost Tomcat server also by
default runs on port 8080 swin speak
already have our Jenkins server running
on port 8080
we cannot let don't get a run on the
same port there will be a port flash so
what I've done I have configured Tomcat
to use a different port so if I go to
this configuration file here there is a
server wrote XML
let me open this up here
all right okay so this is the port by
default it will be 8080
I have just modified it to eight to
eighty one so I've changed the port on
which my Tomcat server would run all
right so that's one chain second change
when Jenkins kind of tries to get into
my Tomcat and deploy something for
someone he would need some
authentications so that he'll be alloyed
deployment by Tomcat
so for that I need to create a user on
Tomcat and provide this user credentials
to my Jenkins instance so I would go to
Tomcat users dotted symbol file here
I've already created a user name called
deployer and the password is deployer
and I've added a role called manager -
script manager - script will allow
programmatic access to the Tomcat server
so this is the role that is there so
using this credentials I will enable or
I'll empower Jenkins to get into my
tomcat server and deploy my application
all right only these two things that is
required let me just start my Tomcat
server first so I get into my bin folder
I open a command prompt here and there's
a startup dot bat
it's pretty fast it just takes a few
seconds yes they go Tomcats it was up
and running now this is running on port
8081 so let me just check if that looks
good so localhost 8080 one
okay my Tomcat settle is a pairing that
sounds good the user is already
configured on this that's also fine so
what I will do as a part of my first job
mavin is also installed my system so I'm
good to use mavin as a part of my
Jenkins so I will put up a simple job
now I will say job MVN
webapp call this freestyle job that's
good
okay so this will be a git repository
what is the URL of my git repository is
this guy HTTP URL okay that's this URL I
will use the credentials the old
trenches that a set up will work well
because it's the same get user that I'm
kind of connecting into all right so now
the change happens here where I after I
get this since I said this is a simple
man one repository I will have some
mavin targets to run
so the simple target first is let me run
mavin packaged this creates a war file
okay so in VN package is the target
package is the target so when whenever I
run this package it kind of creates it
it builds it it tests it and then
creates a package so this is all that is
required maybe let me try to save this
and let me first run this and see if it
connects well if there's any problem
with my war file or the war file gets
created properly
okay wonderful so it built a war file
and if you see it all shows you what is
the location where this war file was
generated
so this is will be the workspace if you
see this this warfare he was
successfully built now I need to grab
this particular war file and then I
would need to deploy it into Tomcat
server again I would need a small plugin
to do this because I need to connect
Tomcat with my Jenkins server let me go
ahead and install the plugin for the
container deployment so I will go to
manage plugins available
type in containers
continual container
deploy to container okay so this would
this the plug-in that I would need I
will install it without early start
right seems very fast
not sorry it's still installing
okay it installed the plugin so if at
all you see this if you go to my
workspace
okay in the target for
replication war finally this already
bailed so I would need to configure this
plugin to pull up this war file and
deploy it onto the Tomcat server for
deploying under the Tomcat server I will
use the currency ins of the user that
I've created okay so let me go to
configure this particular project again
and okay all this is good
so the package is good I'm going to just
create a package that's all fine now
I had a post build step so after the war
file is built as a part of this package
your directive let me use this
deployment to container now if this will
show up after you install the plugin so
deploy this one to the container now
what is that you're supposed to specify
you're supposed to specify the what is
the location okay so this is a global
you know configuration that is there
that will allow you to
from the root folder it'll pick up the
water file that is there so star star
forward slash star dot war that's good
for me okay what is the context path
context path is nothing but just the
name of an application that you know
under which it will get deployed into
the Tomcat so what I will just say in VN
web app that's the name of my thing now
I need to specify what kind of a
container that I'm talking about all
right so the deployment would be for the
stunk at 8.5 is what I need okay because
the server that we have is a tomcat 8.5
server that I have so this would be the
URL so the credentials yes I need to add
a credential for this particular server
so if you remember I had created a
credential for my web application so let
me just find that my Tomcat server
yes configuration of this
okay so deployer and deployer user name
is deployer password is deployed okay so
let me use that credential I would say I
would say add a new credential Jenkins
credential the user name is deployer and
the password is apply
so I would use this deploy credentials
for that and what is the URL of my
Tomcat instance so this is the URL of my
Duncan instance so take the word file
that is fine found in this particular
folder and then you know context path is
a min ever have used the deploy or
deployment credentials and get into this
local host which is their 8081
this is the Tomcat server that is
running on my system and then go ahead
and deploy it okay so that is all that
is required so I would say just save
this and let me run it now
okay it built successfully built the war
file it is trying to deploy it and looks
like a deployment went ahead perfectly
well so
was in being the bap so if I type in
this
all right if at all I go ahead into my
Tomcat server there would be a web apps
folder you would see the you know the
date/time stamp so this is the file that
get caught recently copied and this is
the Explorer version of our application
so the application was built the source
code of this application was pulled from
the github server it was built locally
on the Jenkinson's test and then it was
pushed into a tomcat server which is
running on a different port which is
802.1 now for this demo I am running
everything locally on my system but
assuming that you know this particular
tomcat instance was running on some
other server with some other different
IP address all that you gotta go and
change is the URL of the server so this
would be the server in case you you
already have that you know I have a
tomcat server which is running on some
other machine that's all fine with a
different IP that's all good enough the
whole bundle or the word file that was
built as a part of this Jenkins job gets
transferred on to the other server and
gets deployed that's the beauty of
Jenkins and automatic deployments or
other deployments using Jenkins and my
own distributed build or master slave
configuration in Jenkins as you would
have seen you know we just have one
instance of Jenkins server up and
running all the time and also I told you
that whenever any job that kind of you
know get started on the Jenkins server
it is little heavy on on in terms of
disk space and the CPU utilization so
which kind of you know if at all you're
in an organization where in you're
heavily reliant on the Jenkins server
you don't want your Jenkins server to go
down so that's where in you kind of
start distributing the load that is
there on the Jenkins server so you prime
will have a server which is just a
placeholder or like a master who will
take in all the kind of jobs and what
he'll do is a based upon trigger that
has happened to the job or whichever job
needs to be built he if at all he can
delegate these jobs on to some of the
machines or some of the slaves you know
that's a wonderful thing to have okay
use kiss want use kiss - assuming that
you know if you have a Jenkins server
that is running on a Windows box or on
Linux one and if at all you have a need
where you need to build based upon
operating systems you have multiple
build configurations to support maybe
you need to build a Windows you know
Windows based dotnet kind of a projects
where you would need a Windows machine
to build this particular project you
also have a requirement where you want
to build Linux Linux based systems
you also have a Mac you you support some
surfen apps or something that is built
on Mac OS you would need to build you
know Mac based system as well so how are
you gonna support all these needs so
that's we're in a beautiful concept of
master/slave our you know primary and
delegations or agent and master comes
into play so typically you would have
one Jenkins server who will just you
know configured with all the proper
authorizations users configurations and
everything is set up on this Jenkins
server his job is just delegations he
will listen to some stuff for triggers
or based upon the job that is coming in
he will if there is a very nice way of
delegating these jobs to somebody else
and you know taking back the results he
can control lord of other systems and
these systems may not have a complete or
there's no need to put in a complete
Jenkins installation all that you got to
do is have a very very simple Runner or
a sleeve that's a simple jar file that
is run as a low priority thread or a
process within these systems so with
that you can have a wonderful
distributed server that can be set up
and in case one of the service goes down
your master would know that what went
down and kind of delegate the task to
somebody else so this is the kind of
distributed build or the master slave
configuration so what I'll do in this
exercise or in this demo is I will set
up a simple slave but since I don't have
too many machines to kind of player on
what I will do is I will set up a slave
in in one other folder within my hard
drive so I've got the C Drive and D
Drive my Jenkins is on my C Drive so
what I do is I would just use my
II drive and set up a very very simple
slave out there I'll just show you how
to provision the slave and how to
connect to a slave and how to delegate a
job to that slave let me go back to my
Jenkins master and configure him to you
know talk to an agent so there are
various ways in which this client and
server talk to each other what I'm going
to choose is something called as jnlp
Java networked launch protocol so using
this I would ensure that you know the
client and server talk to each other so
for that I need to ensure that I kind of
enable this jnlp port
so let me try to find out where is that
they will try this
okay yes agents and by default this jnlp
agents thing would be disabled so if you
see here there's a small help on this so
I'm going to use this jnlp which is
nothing but Java a network launch
protocol and you know I'll configure the
master and server to talk to each other
using jnlp so for that I need to enable
this guy so I enable this guy instead of
making the by default the configuration
was disabled so I'm making random and
make him you know enabled and I say save
this configuration all right so now were
configured or I made a setting for the
master so that the journal P port is
kind of opened up so let me go ahead and
you know create an agent so I go to
manage nodes so if you see here there's
only one master here
so let me provision the new node here so
this is the way you know in which you
bring up a new node you have to
configure it on the server Jenkins would
put in some sort of security around this
particular agent and let you know how to
launch this particular agent so that he
can connect to our Jenkins master so I
would say new node I would give a name
for my node I would say Windows node
because both of these are Windows only
so that's fine I just give an identifier
saying that Windows node I would say
this is a permanent agent I'll say ok so
if you see the name let me just copy
this name here with the description
number of executors since it's a slave
node and both of these are running on my
system I will keep the number of
executors as one that's fine
remove root directory now this is where
let me just clarify this since I have
both my my master is running on my c
drive c drive program files 86 or not
not 86 c colon program files
it is indeed 86
all right Jenkins so this is where my
master is running so I don't want the C
Drive what I will do is I will use
something called as a drive I have
another drive in my system but please
visualize this like you know you're
running this on a separate system all
together so I create a folder here
called Jenkins node and this is where
I'm going to place my or I'm going to
provision my slave and I'm going to run
him from here so this is the directory
in which I am going to provision my
slave node so I'm going to copy this
here and that is the remote root
directory of your particular agent of
sleep so I just copied here the label
you know probably this is fine for me
and usage how do you want to use this
guy so I would don't want him to run all
kinds of jobs
I will only build jobs with label
expressions that match this particular
node and so this is the label of this
node so in order for somebody to kind of
delegate any task to them they are got
to specify this particular label so
imagine this way if I have a bunch of
windows my system I named it as Windows
star anything that says from Windows I
can give a regular expression and say
that anything that matches Windows run
this particular task there if I have
some Mac machines I name all these
magazines as Mac star or something of
that and I can delegate all tasks you
know saying that start with whatever
starts with Mac and this node run the
Mac jobs there so you identify a node
using the label and then delegate the
task there all right so launch method
you know we will use Java Web Start
because we got
you got to use jnlp protocol okay that
sounds good
directory I think nothing else is
required availability yes we'll keep
this agent yep
online as much as possible that sounds
good all right let me see if this
alright I'm just provisioning this
particular node now so if I click on
this node I get a bunch of commands
along with an agent or char so this is
the agent or chart that has to be taken
down to the other machine or the slave
node and from there I need to run this
along with a small security credential
so let me copy this whole text here in
my notepad not bad
plus plus is good for me ok pick up with
this whole
but there I also want to download this
island or jar I would say yes
this agent or jar is the one that is
configured by our server so all the
details that is required for launching
this agent or jar is found in this sorry
for launching this agent is found his
agent or jar
so typically I need to take this jar
file onto the other system
and then kind of running from there so I
have this alien rod jar
I copy this or I cut this I come back to
my folder man Jenkins Knoll I paste it
here
okay so now with this provision agent
jar and I need to use this whole command
control a control C and then launch this
particular agent so let me bring up a
command from right here and then lost it
so I'm saying in the same folder where
there is agent or jar I'm going to
launch this particular agent Java - jar
is into jar jnlp this is the URL of my
server in case the server and client are
on different locations or different IPS
never specify the IP address all this
anyway would show up and then the secret
and you know the root folder of your
Jenkins or the slave node
okay
so something ran and then you know it
says it connected very well it seems to
connected very well so let me come back
to my Jenkins instance and see you know
if at all you see earlier this was not
connected alone let me refresh this guy
okay now these two guys are connected
provision a Jenkins node and then I
copied all the credentials of this
Labrador jar along with the launch code
and then took it to the other system and
kind of ran it from there
since I don't have another system I've
just got a separate directory in another
folder and on the drive and I'm
launching the agent from here as long as
this particular agent is up and running
or this command prompt is up and running
the agent would be connected so once I
close this the connection goes down all
right so successfully you've launched
this particular agent now this would be
the home directory of this Jenkins node
or the Jenkins slave so any task that
I'm going to delegate to this particular
slave would all be run here it'll create
a workspace right here all right so good
so let me just come back and let me kind
of put up a new task here I will say
that you know then I get job is good
I say freestyle project I'm going to
create a very very simple job here
I don't want it to come to gate or
anything of that let me just create a
very very simple echo
related to the slave I get it - I don't
like the word slave and I get it - agent
put it this way
all right so delegate it to agent sounds
good now how am I gonna ensure that this
particular job runs on the agent or on
the slave that I have configured right
do you see this if at all you remember
how we provisioned our particularly we
give a label right so now I'm going to
put in a job that will only match this
particular label
so I'm going to say that whatever
matches this you know windows label run
this job on that particular node so we
have only one node that's matching this
in Windows node so this job will be
delegated out there so I save this and
I'm able is
this is again a very very simple job
there's nothing in this I just want to
demonstrate how to kind of delegate it
to an agent so if you see this it ran
successfully and where is the workspace
the workspace is right inside our
Jenkins node it created a new workspace
telling it a job it put in here so my
old or the Maya primary master our job
is in C colon program files and Jenkins
and this is the slaves of that was
successfully run very very simple but
very very powerful concept of master
slave configuration or distributed by
Lynn Jenkins okay
approaching the final section where
you've done all this hard work in
bringing a bunch and conserver
configuring it putting up some jobs on
it creating users and all this stuff now
we don't want this configuration to kind
of go away we want a very nice way of
ensuring that we backup all this
configuration and in case there is any
failure hardware crash or a machine
crash we want to kind of restore from
the existing configuration that we kind
of backed up the one quick way to do
that would be or one dirty way to do
that would be just you know take a
complete backup of a Seco colon program
files : Jenkins directory because that's
where our whole Jenkins configuration is
present but we would don't want to do
that let's use some plugins for taking
up a backup let me go to manage Jenkins
and click on available and let me search
for somebody they're a bunch of backup
plugins so I would recommend one of
these plugins that I specifically use
also this is the backup plug-in so let
me go ahead and install this plug-in
all right so we went ahead and install
this plugin so let me come back to my
manage plugins plugins there so hang on
backup manager so you will see this
option once you install this plug-in so
first time I can you know do a setup I
would say backup this particular I'll
give a folder this folder is pertaining
to the folder where I want Jenkins to
backup some data and I would say the
format should be zip format is good
enough let me give a name or template or
a file name for my you know backup this
is good I won't read in verbose mode I
don't want to share on my Jenkins or
should I shut it down no okay one thing
that you got to remember is that
whenever a backup happens there are too
many jobs that is running on the server
it can kind of slow down your Jenkins
instance because it's it's the process
of copying few of those things and if
the files have being changed at that
moment it's little bit problematic for
Jenkins so typically you backup your
servers only when there is very less
load or typically try to you know bring
it to a share own kind of a state and
then take a backup all right so I'm
gonna back up all these things you know
I don't want to exclude anything else I
want the history I want daemon artifacts
possibly I don't want this guy I would
just save and then I would say back him
up so this would run a bunch of you know
steps and all the files that is required
as a part of this is pretty fast but
then if at all you have too many things
up on your server for now we didn't have
too many things up on our server but in
case you had too many things to kind of
back up this may take a while so let me
just pause this recording and get back
to you once the backup is complete so
there you go the backup was successful
created a backup of all the workspace
the configurations the users and you
know all that so all this is kind of
hidden down in this particular zip file
so at any instance if at all I kind of
crashed my system for some instance or
say hard disk failure and I bring up a
new instance of Jenkins I can kind of
use the backup plug-in for restoring
this particular
configurations so how do I do that I
just come back to my managing canes come
back to backup manager and I will say
restore Hudson
Jenkins configuration that concludes our
tutorial on Jenkins thank you for
stopping by and watching this video hope
it was useful for you and inspire you to
get your hands dirty with Jenkins and I
play around with it for more learnings
please do visit us at
www.simpleandsensational.com